اذا يمثل في هذه الاثناء الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه في فلوريدا بتهم جنائيه هذه
التهم تتعلق باحتفاضه بشكل غير قانوني
بوثائق ترتبط بالامن القومي عندما ترك
منصبه وكذلك بكذبه على المسؤولين الذين
سعوا لاستعاده هذه الوثائق وفي جلسه
الاستماع لن يتم التصوير او استعمال
الهواتف ومن المرجح ان يقف ترامب الى جانب
محاميه حتى يمنحه القاضي الاذن بالتحدث
وينضم الينا من واشنطن تنضم الينا مديره
مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ناديه البلبيسي
ومن امام المحكمه الفيدراليه في ميامي
حسين التاود مراسل العربيه اسمحيلي ناديه
بعد اذنك ان ابدا مع حسين لاعرف منه ما
الذي يراه ويسمع الان هناك وما الذي يعرف
عما يجري داخل المحكمه
تحيه لك طاهر وتحيه لك راويه بالفعل ما
زالت الحشود غفيره ولكن شعرنا انه بعد
وصول ترامبوله الان امام القاضي بان
الحماس خفض قليلا ولكن طبعا الاعداد زادت
عما كانت عليه في ساعات الصباح الاولى
عندما اتينا الى هنا على الساعه التاسعه
صباحا ما زال الجميع طبعا ينتظر خروج
ترامب ربما سيكون هناك مزيد من الاجواء
الحماسيه كما كانت قبل وصوله الى هنا
علمنا ان خلال الصباح كان هناك محاميان
قدما اوراقهما لتمثيل ترامبو الحضور معه
امام القاضي بالنسبه لما قد يجري الان
هناك اعتقاد كبير يتم الحديث عنه في وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه بانه تكرار لسيناريو ما
جرى معه في نيويورك ستؤخذ بصماته ولكن
اعتقد انها ستؤخذ الكترونيا ايضا لن تاخذ
له صوره ماكشوط هو رئيس الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهو شخصيه معروفه بحاجه الى ذلك
بعدما يتم
القاء توم او اعلنتهم له
يقول بانه غير مذنب وعندما ينتهي كل هذا
الامر سيعود الى
حسين نطلع المشاهدين على انه اقر بعدم
ذنبه في هذه الاتهامات التي تلاها
جونسون غودمان لائحه الاتهامات تلاها اذا
قاضي الصلح جونسون غودمان ونفاهه ترامب
نفاتها من المواجهه اليه بقضيه الوثائق
السريه راويه
العادل بانه عمليه اعتقال ترامب ومساعده
قد اكتملت وفقا للاجراءات القضائيه هل ذلك
يعني بانه
الاصفاد وضعت في يده يعني حسين قال بانه
لم يصور لانه معروف وكان رئيس للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هل وضعت الاصفاد في يده
كاي مواطن امريكي متهم
لا رغم اننا نعرف بان الرئيس كما يقول
الادعاء ولجنه المحامين والمحكمه بانه
سيعامل مثل اي امريكي تقدم ضده لائحه
اتهام لكن بالنهايه هو رئيس سابق ما نعرفه
ان الرئيس لم يقيد رغم انه كان
رهن الاعتقال باي معنى بمعنى بانه طالما
ان هناك ادله
قررت هيئه المحلفين ان تقدم لائحه الاتهام
وان يواجه المحاكمه عليه اما ان يبقى في
مكاني وبالتالي عناصر من الشرطه تذهب
لاعتقاله او ان يسلم نفسه الطواعيه وما
رايناه كما راينا في محكمه نيويورك ذهب
الرئيس طواعيه ودخل الى هذا المبنى وطبعا
حسب قوانين المحكمه الفيدراليه ليس لانه
رئيس سابق لا يمكن ان يكون هناك تصوير بكل
اشكاله سواء كان تصوير الفوتوغرافي او
فيديو لكن ايضا في العاده كما ذكرت هناك
ما يسمى بالماكشوت اي صوره لهذا المتهم
اذا كان شخص عادي لكن لانه رئيس قد يكون
هناك عمليه تسييس لاستخدام هذه الصوره
لجني اموال او غيرها وبالتالي قررت
المحكمه ان تستعين بصور سابقه للرئيس وانت
تستخدمها عوضا عن هذه الصور التي تلتقت
عاده عندما يظهر الرئيس
رهن الاعتقال هل يحاكم او يعامل كاي
امريكا عادي اكيد لا لكن بشكل عام كما
تعرفين هناك اختلاف طبعا بالنسبه للقضايا
القانونيه ما بين ترامب وما بين
اي شخص اخر فقط لانه كونه رئيس وكما ذكرت
قبل قليل وكما هو متوقع من الرئيس ترامب
بانه بالعاده قال بانه غير مذنب وسيصر
بانه غير مذنب وسيتهم وزاره العدل هنا
خلفي في واشنطن التي قررت ان تنقل المحكمه
من هنا
ما يعني حتى لا تتهم بالتسيس لهذه القضيه
لانه كما تعرفين واشنطن هي مقاطعه وعاصمه
ديمقراطيه بامتياز وبالتالي عندما يتم
اختيار هيئه المحلفين لمقاضره ترامب سيكون
الاغلبيه من الديمقراطيه تبقينا معنا
ناديه اذا ترامب يدفع ببراءته في هذه
الجلسه ويقول انا غير مذنب بقضيه الوثائق
السريه امام قضاه محكمه ميامي في فلوريدا
من حيث تاتينا من هذه الصور الجويه لكل
المحيط محيط هذه المحكمه وبالتالي نسال
حسين مجددا وهو هناك عن الاجراءات المقبله
ما بعد الدفع ببراءته ماذا نتوقع من
اجراءات
ماذا تتوقع قانونيا ام سياسيا طاهر لنبدا
القانونيه اذا اذا هذا الامر واضح يعني ما
هي الاجراءات التي نتوقعها بعد الدفع
ببراءته ثم لاحقا ربما نناقش او نعرف اكثر
عن التبعات السياسيه
قانونيا من
الاحتمال الاكبر ان يغادر
يطلق سراحه وان يغادر كما هو متوقع كما
قلنا وان يعود الى
نيوجيرسي طبعا المحاكمه ستبدا فيما بعد
بعد هذا اليوم وسيكون هناك محامون له
يتابعون القضيه
وستتكلف القاضيه ايلين نسيت اسمها
بمحاكمته
عفوا شكرا لك
بتولي امورها هذه المحاكمه هذا على
الناحيه القانونيه طبعا هذا قد ياخذ وقتا
كثيرا هناك من يقول بان محاموسه يحاولون
اطاله امد هذه المحاكمه على امل ان يحصل
على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري وعلى امل ايضا
ان يصبح رئيسا لكي يلغي هذه المحرك يطلب
من وزاره العدل الغاء هذه المحاكمه في
المستقبل اذا بالفعل نجح واصبح رئيسا
للولايات المتحده الان السياسيه ماذا
سيجري دونالد ترامب مصر على رايه بانه
مظلوم بان هذه تهم سياسيه الدوافع
السياسيه بانها مطارده سياسيه له
ويتهم وزاره العدل بتاسيس القضاء وبان كل
ما يجد من توجيهتهم لا وقف خلفه الرئيس
الحالي لانه وفق ترامب هو متراجع في
استطلاعات الراي عنه ويريد ان يحطم من
ترامب لكي يفوز عليه هذا حسب ترامب وحسب
ما يؤمن به ايضا الجمهوريون المؤيدون له و
هم القاده الشعبيه وعدد من القاده في مجلس
النواب مثل قبل مقارتي ومثل ستيف ستاليز
وعدد ايضا من
السيناتورز البارزين مثل لينزي غرام الذي
وان اقروا بان ترامب اخطا بالتعامل مع
الوثائق ولكنهم يعتبرون ان كل هذه العمليه
لها دوافع سياسيه
اذا تشامب ينفي نذكر من جديد طاهر 37 تهمه
الموجهه اليه امام محكمه ميامي اعود اليك
ناديه يعني وقع هذه المحاكمه التاريخيه
لاول مره ترامب باخطر مواجهه مع القضاء
الامريكي لاول مره رئيس سابق امام محكمه
وتهمه فيدراليه وقعها على الشارع
هناك انقسام في الشارع الامريكي منذ ان
تولى الرئيس ترامب اداره البيت الابيض
وشؤون البلاد لكن الان في ظل هذه
الملاحقات القانونيه هناك شريحه في الحزب
الجمهوري البعض يرى بانه طبعا هي مواليه
ومخلصه للرئيس ترامب منذ البدايه البعض
يرى بانه حتى الرئيس ترامب استطاع ان يغير
الحزب الجمهوري اصبح حزب ترامبي اذا اردت
بهذا التعبير اكثر منه حزب جمهوري تقليدي
وبالتالي الانقسام واضح يعني هناك بعض
الشخصيات المرموقه في داخل مجلس الشيوخ
بالتحديد مثل السنتر يلتزم الصمت بمعنى
بانه لا يؤيد ترامب وهناك مرشحين جمهوريين
منهم مايك بينس ومنهم نيكي هيلي ومنهم
تمسكوت وغيرهم يخشون على انتقاد علني
للرئيس ترامب لانه بالفعل هم يعرفونا داخل
انفسهم بانه تجاوز القانون حتى يحافظ هذه
الشريحه المخلصه له في حال كانت هناك ربما
عواقب قانونيه جديه يمكن ان تمنع ترامب من
الترشح او الفوز على الاقل
بالحزب الجمهوري او بالفوز بترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري لذا هذا الانقسام موجود منذ
اليوم الاول الديمقراطيين لا يتحدثون
كثيرا لانه البيت الابيض يلتزم الصمت كما
تعرفين لكن الباقي يرى بانه الرئيس تجاوز
القانون وبالتالي لا احدا فوق القانون ولا
فوق الدستور رئيس سابق رئيس حالي الجميع
سيواجه القضاء وبالتالي يقولون بانه هذا
الشخص غير مؤهل لان يقود الولايات المتحده
في المرحله القادمه في ولايه ثانيه رغم ان
القانون والدستور لا يمنعه من الترشح لان
هناك ثلاث شروط فقط للترشح هو ان يكون قد
بلغ 35 عاما وان يكون قد قضى 14 عمل منا
في الولايات المتحده وان يكون مولود في
الولايات المتحده حتى لو اتهم جنائيا
من الترشح قانونيه لكن عمليا سيكون صعب
جدا كيف يمكن للرئيس ان يحكم من السجن عدا
عن ذلك هذا قد يؤثر في مجموع الاصوات وقد
لا يفوز بالنهايه ترامب بترشح حزبي شكرا
جزيلا لك ناديه البلبيسي مديره مكتبه مكتب
العربيه في واشنطن ومن امام المحكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي حسين التوت العربيه
احسنه وناديه شكرا لكم شكرا جزيلا
لكن ما هي العقوبات المحتمله بحق ترامب
صحيفه امريكيه قالت ان الرئيس السابق قد
يواجه حكما بالسجن ل 22 عاما اما المدعي
العام السابق ديفيد دارون فقال ان ترامب
قد يواجه سبعه وتسع سنوات اضافيه في السجن
بسبب عرقله سير العداله
لكن من المتحكم في كل هذا انها القاضيه
ايلين كان التي عينها ترامب قبيله تركي
منصبه والتي يلاحقها الجدل وهي الاخرى
واصل الامر الى حد مطالبتها بالتنحي
والسبب شبهه تضارب المصالح
[موسيقى]
الان يسمح للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب بمغادره المحكمه بدون شروط وفقا لسي
ان ان
لن يتم اعتقاله
طبعا الناحيه القانونيه سنناقشها مع ضيفنا
من نيويورك
الباحث في كليه الحقوق في جامعه نيويورك
اهلا بك يعني
ماذا عن الدفعات استمعنا الى لائحه
الاتهام اللي هي من 37 اتهاما ما الذي
يقوله ترامب بمعنى او فريق دفاعه دائما
عندما يتحدث في خطاباته يتحدث بانه هذه
مؤامره سياسيه هناك تاسيس هناك مهاجمه لي
لمنع من الوصول الى البيت الابيض من جديد
ولكن من الناحيه القانونيه كيف يمكن
الدفاع عن نفسه ما الذي يمكن ان يقدمه
ليبرر انه لن ينتهك سريه ملفات ووثائق لا
يجب ان تكون معه بحسب ما يقول القضاء طبعا
الامريكي
سوف تكون المساله في غايه التعقيد
الامر الاول الذي قد يسعى لمحاولته هو
ان
يتم توفير الشريط الذي تم تسجيل فيه
محادثه الرئيس مع صحفي
بانه بحوزته بعض المستندات السريه
وكان يتحدث عن مع شخص من مجلس الامن
القومي سوف يتم اذا قد يتم استثناء هذه
الشريط او تلك المحادثه من الادله واي
ادله اخرى قد تقدم من قبل
الادعاء سوف يعمل فريق الدفاع
للرد عليها
لكن اذا ما تم استثنائي الشريط الذي فيه
الذي يحتوي على المحادثه
فقد يكون وضع الرئيس
يحكم عليهم مما اذا كان قد قام فعليا بتلك
الانتهاكات
فهناك جدل كثير كان يدور حول اذا مكانه
تلك المستندات سريه من عدمه
واذا ما كان القانون يقضي بان تكون سريه
او اذا ما رفعت عنها السريه من اجل الحفاظ
على على تلك المعلومات التي تمسها الامن
الداخلي من المؤكد ان الاسرار التي تتعلق
باسلحه النوويه وبعض الاجراءات العسكريه
التي تتخذ بحق دول اخرى
سوف تكون مستندات طبعا سريه لكن ما من احد
يعلم ما الذي سوف يفعلونه يعني الفريق
الفريق القانوني للدفاعي عن كل هذه
الجرائم
هذا الفريق الذي تتحدث عنه كان في حاله
تغير مستمر بعد تعديل كبير شهد الاسبوع
الماضي شاهد استقاله اثنين من محاميه
لماذا باعتقادك وما هي الاثار التي
سيتركها هذا التعديل على الاداء القانوني
لفريقه
فان المحاميين اللذان كان
مسؤولين عن الدفاع
عن الرئيس السابق ترامب قد
استقل وقد يحمل هذا اشاره
بان الرئيس السابق لديه تاريخ في طلب
في تقديم طلبات من محاميه بان يقوموا ببعض
الاعمال قد تكونوا مخالفه للقانون
فاللائحه الاتهامات تحتوي على بعض
التصرفات التي قام بها الرئيس
ويتحمل عنها المسؤوليه بانه كان قد كذب
وقد اخفى الحقيقه عن محاميه السابق فيما
يتعلق بالمساندات التي كان يفترض اعادتها
ما رايناه مع مرور الوقت ان هذه
المسندات كانت موضعه جدلا
الرئيس السابق لديه اراء مختلفه قد تكون
حول ما يجب القيام به وحول ما يجب ان
يمليه من اوامر على محاميه ولا قد لا يقبل
اي محامل بمثل هذه الامور
فلعلي اقول
ان الامر قد يتوقف الان على الدفاع
الحالي الذي سوف يسعى
الرئيس ليكون اكثر حذرا اكثر حذرا في
تصريحاته العلنيه لان عاده هذه التصريحات
العلنيه قد تؤدي الى المزيد من المشاكل
نعم
اود ان اسالك عن القاضيه ايلين كانون الين
كانون هذه القريه التي عينها ترامب منذ
ثلاثه اعوام
ما صلاحياتها بالنسبه للمده الزمنيه التي
ستاخذها هذه المحاكمه خاصه ما يحكى انه
هذه القاضيه مقربه من الحزب الجمهوري
تبرعت عده مرات لمرشحي الحزب بالولايه
وهنا نتحدث عن تضارب المصالح والحياديه
من المحتمل ان يكون هناك تضارب في المصالح
لكن القانون الامريكي يملي على القاضي
بان يتحلى بالحياديه والنزاهه في
عند النظر في القضايا القانونيه ومن
المؤكد ان يكون هناك احتمال ان تعمل وزاره
العدل على الطلب من القاضيه ان تتنحى عن
النظر بهذه القضيه
لان
قد يكون للحكومه التصور
بانه قد تكون لها علاقه وثقه الصله في
ترامب
وقد يكون
هناك تطور في القضيه لتدخل الى مرحله
الطعن
والهيئه التي سوف تكون في المحكمه
قد لاحظت
بان القاضي ايلين
كانت مقربه من الرئيس والان امام وزاره
العدل القرارا لتتخذه اذا ما كانت كانوا
يجب ان تتنحى عن النظر في هذه القضيه
لعدم
نزاهتها لكن لو قررت وزاره العدل بعدم
اتخاذ هذا الامر فالمحاكمه سوف تستغرق
فتره من الزمن وقد تقول القاضي بانه قد لا
يكون هناك اي اسباب تدفع لعدم الحيل الامر
غير واضح حتى اللحظه لكن القانون هو
القانون ويجب ان يطبق بصوره عامه فهناك
اجراءات يجب اتباعها مع الوقت من
اجل البث في مساله نزهتها من عدمه
وقد يتم التوصل الى حل قد يكون مقبولا من
قبل الطرفين
الى المقاطعه ولكن هناك اخبار عاجله تصلنا
نقلا عن بانه لن يتم فرق قيود على سفر
ترامب بعد مثوله امام المحكمه بقضيه
الوثائق السريه كما انه لن يتم فرد كفاله
ماليه مقابل السماح له بمغادره المحكمه
وهنا ربما يمكن نسال ضيفنا
بالقسم الثاني عن ان كانت مؤشرات على عدم
اتجاه المحكمه ربما لفرض احكام كبرى على
ترامب لانه لن يتم عرقله سفره او
اقتياده او ابقاؤه بالمحكمه
على ما هو اتا تبقى معنا استاذ بيتر شين
لو تكرمت اذا مفاجاه اخرى في القضيه ليست
في لائحه الاتهام وانما في فريق الدفاع
فاترامب وجد صعوبات بالغه في استقطاب
محامين من فلوريدا لفريق الدفاع ويعود جزء
من الاسباب للتروم
واجهه ترامب معضله في العثور على محامي
مؤهل من فلوريدا للانضمام الى فريق دفاعه
واشنطن بوست قالت ان محامين بارزين في
فلوريدا رفضوا الترافع عن ترامب بعد
استقاله اثنين من محاميه الرئيسيين
الاسبوع الماضي
اضافت الصحيفه ان ترامب امضى يوم الاثنين
في مقابلات مع محامين محتملين والاجتماع
بفريقه القانوني ومستشاريه لمناقشه القضيه
مستشار لترامب اشار الا ان التوت بلانش
سيقود فريق الدفاع كما فعل في قضيه ترامب
في نيويورك
خبراء قالوا لواشنطن بوست ان ترامب يعاني
في تعيين المحامين منذ انتخابه رئيسا عام
2016 بعدما عرف عنه تجنب المشوره
القانونيه احيانا وعدم الدفع لمحاميه في
احيان اخرى
الان في جديد هذه القضيه اذا مساعد ترامب
وهو والت ناو
يقر يعني يدفع ببراءته في قضيه وثائق
ترامب السريه كما تعرف ناوته هو من قدام
المحاربين في البحريه وكان يعمل في البيت
الابيض راويه وكان مساعدا شخصيا للرئيس
ترامبو وكان توجه ايضا من يوجيرسي الى
فلوريدا ووجهت الى ست تهم في يعني سبتها
خاصه به تشمل التعطيل والاخفاء ووفقا
لرائحه الاتهام فان ناوته هذا تحديدا
مساعد نقل صناديق تخزين او صناديق من غرفه
تخزين كان من المفترض ان يفتشها محامي ردا
على مذكره استدعاء واعاد بعض الصناديق فقط
قبل البحث
المدعون يقولون الان ان النوته ادلى
باقوال كاذبه للمحققين بانه لا يعرف كيف
وصلت هذه الصناديق
وما اذا كان قد تم تامينها او لا اذا هذه
اخر المعلومات عن مساعد ترامب
وهناك تفاصيل جديده فيما يتعلق باحكام
القاضي على ترامب قبل مغادرته من خلال عدم
السماح له
بالتواصل مع شهود معينين او مفترضين في
هذه القضيه وفقا لسي ان نعود الى ما هو
انسان ان نفسها قالت بانه لن يتم فرد قيود
على سفر ترامب نعود اليك سيد بيتر يعني
هذه المعلومات التي تريدها سي ان ان اذا
ببراءه مساعده ترامب بعدم فرض قيود على
سفره ولن يتم فرد كفاله ماليه هل هي
مؤشرات على شيء ما
[موسيقى]
تشين من المؤكد بانني لم اطلع على مجرياتي
المحكمه حتى اللحظه لكن هذا قد ياتي من
قبيل المفاجاه
لا شك فيه بانه كان سوف يرفض المثل امام
المحكمه لان التبعات سوف تكون
كبيره ومن المؤكد ان محاميه قد دفعه
بالحضور وهذا ما حدث ايضا في مثوله امام
المحكمه في نيويورك
وغير المؤكد بانه محاميه قد اوعز اليه
بعدم السفر الى الخارج
واي مدعى عليه اخر متهم بهذه
التهم قد يطلب منه تسليم جواز سفره لكن
الامر لم يطبق بحق ترامب
سعيد يعني ما هي اكثر التهم خطوره
باعتقادك من تلك التي وجهت الى ترامب والى
اي مدى ترى ان هذه التهم جميعها محكمه الى
الحد الذي سيكون صعبا على الاقل على فريق
الدفاع ان يمارس دوره ان لم نقل توجيه
التهم
اعتقد انه سوف يكون الامر صعبا للغايه على
الفريق فريق الدفاع
وخاصه عندما يتعلق بالمعلومات المرتبطه
بالامن القومي
فقد ذكر
بصوره لا تدفع ان السجلات التي بحوزتها في
مارلاجو كانت
سجلات سريه وهذا امر لا يمكن الشك فيه
وكل الادله تشير ان تلك المستندات كانت
سريه
وسوف يتم النظر في الشريط الذي اقر بوجوده
من خلال المحادثه انه يحتوي على معلومات
سريه
لذا
الاقرار بهذين الامرين
لا يمكن ان يكون خاطئين على مستوى اهميتها
من الناحيه القانونيه او بالنسبه
للمستندات القانونيه التي كان يفترض به
اعادتها
اعتقد
ان استراتيجيه فريقي الدفع
قد تكمن في ايجاد بعض الاسس القانونيه
التي يمكن من خلالها ابعاد بعض الادله
الاضافيه عن هيئه المحلفين
والاستمرار باجراء بالاجراءات قدر الامكان
بعيدا عن الوصول الى هذه الادله لان لان
بعد ذلك لن يكون اذا ما تم التوصيل قد
يصعب تبرئه الرئيس
كان على درايه بلائحه الاتهامات التي قدمت
سابقا في نيويورك بحق ترامب وكانت على
مستوى الولايه اما الان
فان الادله كثيره بدات تظهر الى العين
قصه بيتروشين الباحث في كليه الحقوق في
جامعه نيويورك شكرا جزيلا على وجودك معنا
الليله في تغطيتنا الخاصه عبر العربيه
لمحاكمه الرئيس السابق ترامب تحياتي اليك
اذا دونالد ترامب امام القضاء مجددا وهذه
المره بشان قضيه الوثائق السريه التي عثر
عليها في منزله العديد من كبار المسؤولين
الجمهوريين انتقدوا ملاحقه ترامب
واعتبروها استهدافا له بينما تم تجاهل
حوادث قد تبدو مشابهه لما حدث مع ترامب
فما الفارق واشنطن بوست حاولت الاجابه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب يواجه سبعا
وثلاثين تهمه بينها سبع تهم تتعلق
بالاحتفاظ دون وجه حق بوثائق سريه وبرفض
تسليمها اضافه للتامر من اجل عرقله
العداله هنا يمكن تمييز امرين ترامب نقل
الوثائق الى فلوريدا بينما كان الانتقاد
الموجه لهلاري كلينتون وزيره الخارجيه
سابقا هو استخدامها لخادم بريد الكتروني
شخصي لاجراء الاعمال الحكوميه اثناء عملها
الحكومي ما ادى الى مشاركه معلومات سريه
على كمبيوتر او سيرفر غير حكوميه في حاله
كلينتن كانت رسائل البريد الالكتروني
تناقش موضوعات سريه نعم الا انها لم تكن
وثائق سريه بالمعنى التقليدي او وثائق
سريه للغايه وهناك فرق وراجع محامها اكثر
من 60 الف بريد الكتروني سلموا نصفها
لمسؤولين حكوميين بينما تم اعتبار النصف
الاخر شخصيا ايضا ظهرت وثائق سريه لدى
الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن لكنها تتعلق بفتره
ما بعد مغادره منصبه كنائبا للرئيس وعثر
على وثائق في مكتب تابع له في واشنطن
اضافه لمنزله في ويلمنكتم بولايه دالاور
محام بايدن اعلن وانهم تعاونوا في كل
خطوات التحقيق وانهم اعادوا جميع المواد
السريه التي عثر عليها في المكتب والمنزل
الامر ذاته ينطبق على نائب ترامب عندما
اجرى مكتب تحقيقات الفيدرالي بحثا في
منزله بولايه انديانا ليجد عددا من
المستندات التي يحتمل ان تكون حساسه او
سريه هناك في اواخر يناير
ايضا تم تسليم جميع المواد الى السلطات
الحكوميه الى ان اغلقت وزاره العدل القضيه
ليعلن بانس بعدها رسميا عن ترشحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه المقبله
معنا من واشنطن بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن هناك ايضا الدكتور عقيل عباس
الخبير في الشؤون السياسيه الامريكيه اهلا
بكما ونفتح الحوار مع كراويه مع السيد
بشار جرار سيد بشار يعني هل يعقل
التهم الموجهه ضد دون الترامب هي مكائد
سياسيه يعني نتحدث عن تهم كبرى نتحدث عن
اساءه التعامل مع الاسرار اسرار الامن
القومي الامريكي
وبدايه لن اجيب بسؤال ولكن هل يعقل ان
يكون متهما بالفعل في قضيه تجسس يترك هكذا
دون تحديد اقامه دون القاء القبض دون
تحديد على الاقل لو مبلغ مالي على سبيل
فقط الاجراءات القضائيه المتعارف عليها في
قضايا ابسط من ذلك بكثير هذا المسلسل يا
سيدتي بدا منذ كان مرشحا في الانتخابات
السابقه قبل ذلك في 2016 قضيه ملاحقه
مستمره لم تكد تختلف احيانا يتصدر
الملاحقه الاعلام الحر والنزيه لهذا
المرشح واحيانا القضاء الحره النزيع ايضا
يلاحق هذا المرشح الذي اصبح رئيسا والان
يعود لمعركه الترشيح ولخوض هذه الانتخابات
المقبله 20 24 ومن هنا من غير المعقول هذا
الاستهداف ليس لرئيس سابق وهي سابقه بحد
ذاتها ولكن الاكثر خطوره هو استهداف مرشح
رئاسي شبه مؤكد حصوله على دعم الحزب
الجمهوري وشبه مؤكد ايضا انه قادر على
هزيمه بايدن بعد هذه هي الفضائح المتراكمه
منذ الانتخابات السابقه على
جو بايدن والتي وفق ما قيل مؤخرا هذا اقل
من 24 ساعه بان هناك سبعه عشره مكالمه
محادثه تم التسجيل فيها بين بريزما هذه
الشركه الاوكرانيه وبين هنتر بايدن خمسه
عشر خمسه عشره مكالمه
ومكالماتين مع الرئيس عندما كان نائبا
للرئيس فهناك سلسله متكامله من الاستهداف
في مقابل التغطيه على اين يجب ان يكون
تركيز الاعلام واين هو التركيز القضاء لو
كانت بالفعل حرا ونزيها حتى القضايا التي
طرحت كلها واشنطن بوست وكان هناك نوع من
الحمله المتواصله تبقى معنا خلينا نشوف
استاذ عقيل شو عنده ملاحظات على ما تفضلت
به دكتور عقيل
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه تحيه لك الكريم
اعتقد التهم الموجهه للرئيس سابق ترامب
تهم خطيره تهم جديه يعني محاوله التصوير
على انها مسيسه قبل الدخول في الجوله
القضائيه اعتقد هذه محاوله متسرعه يعني
واحده من التهمه التي برزت انه الرئيس فقط
اعاقه تسليم الوثائق وهذه عليها ادله
وادله كثيره موثقه لكنه ايضا
اباح بعض الاسرار لاناس ليسوا مخولين يعني
مثلا خطط عسكريه للبنتاجون خطط طوارئ
باذاع بلد اخر الحديث يعني تحدث على اساس
هذه الوثائق الحديث بخصوص نقاط الضعف
الدفاع الامريكيه التي يمكن ان تستهدفها
بلدان اخرى عن الترسان النوويه هذه اشياء
جديه وخطيره
مع شخص اخر تحديدا دكتور عقيل اسال السيد
بشار يعني هل ينظر الجمهوريون بنفس
الطريقه على قضيه امن قومي عن اسرار دوله
عن اسرار الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كقضيه اخرى قضيه عدم رضا ترامب عن نتائج
الانتخابات او القضيه التي حكم او تم
اتهامه فيها بشان الممثله الامريكيه هل
يعني يتم تسويه كل هذه القضايا بنفس
المستوى
راويه طاهر ودكتور عقيل وجمهور العربيه
اعتقد ان الجميع يذكر عندما كان الرئيس في
ذلك الحين مرشحا يواجه عندما قال وجعل
يديه هكذا وقال يا روسيا اليك الرجاء
الكشف عن ايميلات هيرل كلينتون في اشاره
الى قضيه السيرفر هذا السيرفر الذي لم
تكشف الصحافه الحره والنزيهه ان مساعديه
قاموا
بتهشيمه في في هروات
هذه الفضائح المرتبطه التي سببت بمقتل
السفير الامريكي الاول في ليبيا
بسبب الاهمال والتقصير هذه قضايا الامن
القومي معروفه عندما كان يقول الرئيس
ترامب مرشحا ورئيسا ان لدينا مشكله في هذه
الحروب اللامتناهيه في الشرق الاوسط هذا
الانفاق اكثر من سبعه على الشرق الاوسط
الذي نخسره
هذا يعتبر من وجهه نظر المؤسسات التقليديه
المرتبطه بالدوله العميقه تعتبر نوع من
الافشاء وان هذا يؤثر على صوره امريكا
وجديتها لكن العكس تماما ما يجري هو وهذا
مثال اخر يظهر الى اي مدى هناك نفاق في
الصحافه وفي القضاء نعم واقولها بلا تردد
قضيه لما عندما قال الثقاله الصحافه
والاوساط السياسيه في واشنطن بانه لابد من
التحقق من مكالمه الرئيس ترامب مع
سيلينسكي وكلنا نعلم من هو الان
مجرد مكالمه وتم عزل
ترامبنت الاول كان مركزا على هذه القضيه
اتساءل لماذا لا يطلبون الان
مكالمات سبعه عشره مكالمه فيها ابتزاز من
شركه قامت بتعيين نجل بايدن وهو هنتر
بايدن الذي من الذي قالت
امضخ واحد وخمسين مسؤول استخبارات يقولون
الامن القومي 51 قالوا بان هنتر بايدن
واللابتوب
وان هذه المساله مرتبطه بالمخابرات
الروسيه تبين كذب ذلك من الذي اخذ جائزه
على هذا التحقيق صحفي دون ذكر اسماء ونادى
صحافه تقدير عاليه جدا في المجتمع المخملي
الذي يشار اليه بالبنان تبين انه غير صحيح
نقاط الخاصه
اثبتت ان هذا الامر فهي مساله يا سيدتي
واخي الكريم ولز
ميلي كشفت
وازدواجيه المعايير في القضاء الامريكي
وفي الصحافه
النظر هذه الى الاستاذ عقيل يعني هذه
الاسئله التي طرحها ضيفنا الكريم لا تثير
الشكوك ايضا خاصه لجهه تسييس القضاء او
لجهه يعني عدم اثاره قضايا اخرى ضد الرئيس
الحالي ونجله بقضايا باتت معروفه ومثاره
في الاعلام منذ سنوات ولكن لا تاخذ طريقها
او نصيبها القضائي
يعني اولا هذه القضايا اثيرت وما تزال
مثاره في اوساط معينه سياسيه بالذات بحزب
الجمهوري اما بخصوص اثارتها رسميا نحن
نتحدث عن كان يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون
واثاره قضيه
كثيرا وبشكل معمق وبشكل مكرر نفس الشيء
بخصوص قضيه هنتر بايدن اثارها بشكل مكرر
وتحقيقات ولم يصلوا الى نتيجه نحن نتحدث
عن كونجرس كان يسيطر عليه الجمهوريون ولم
ياتوا بدليل جرمي اما قضيه يعني الرئيس
ترامبو
واضحه جدا يعني حدوث الاتصال والطلب اليه
انه يبحث ما سماه يعني
اشياء سلبيه بخصوص الرئيس بايدن بل
وايقافه المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا على
مدى فتره الى ان يكمل هذه القضايا السياسي
تختلف
لو كان ترامب ليس ترامب لو كان اي موظف
حكومي اخر او اي مواطن امريكي اخر متهم
هذه التهم المتعلقه بالامن القومي هل كان
سمح له بمغادره المحكمه هل كان سمح له
يعني ان يكون حرا ان يسافر وان لا يدفع
يعني اي دولار مقابل مغادرته المحكمه يعني
هناك علامات استفهام حقيقيه حول هذا
الموضوع يعني
هذه جزئين انا اتفق فيها مع حضرتك ترامب
يتلقى معامله تفضيليه بالمناسبه هل هي
تفضيليه او لانه ليس هناك يمكن من دلائل
حقيقيه
لا علينا ان ننتظر ونرى هل ستكون هناك
قيود عليه في المحكمه اعتقد ستكون عليه
بعض القيود لن يستطيع ان يسافر للايام كل
الاماكن التي يريدها بعضها سيحتاج ان يبلغ
الوقت مبكر يعني انه هذه
لا اعتقد ستكون عليه بعض القيود لكنه ايضا
الموضوع يعني يثير احراج سياسيا وقانونيا
هذه لاول مره رئيس سابق يتعرض او يمر
بتجربه كهذه علينا ان نتذكر ذهب الى السجن
مباشره القي القبض عليه وصور واخذ رغم انه
الذي قام به يعني نحتاج رايا قانونيا
وقضائيا دقيقا اقل بكثير مما به الرئيس
ترامب
هذا جندي وهذا رئيس سابق اعتقد الاسئله
بخصوص الازدواجيه يمكن ان تثار على الجانب
الاخر بمعنى انه يتلقى معامله تفضيليه
يعني اولا عموما في جوانب عديده ليست فقط
قانونيه وانما نفسيه ايضا
تستعرضها لنا راويه في هذا العرض المقبل
اذا تبقى يان معنا لو تكرمتما
اذا بينما تستمر هذه التحقيقات حول الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق دونالد ترامب يسير هو على
مسارين قانوني واخر نفسي ونفسي لديه يعني
اثاره الغضب والغضب ثم الغضب في نفوس
انصاره يوم امس وعند انتقاله من نيوجيرسي
الى فلوريدا تعهد ترامب بالانتقام السياسي
من لائحه الاتهام التاريخيه الموجهه له
بتهمه اساءه التعامل مع وثائق سريه وفي
منشور له على موقعه تروس سوشل توعد ترامب
بتعيين ما اسماه مدعيا خاصا حقيقيا لتحقيق
وملاحقه جو بايدن وعائلته ما يوضح
استراتيجيه ترامب السياسيه في مواجهه
التهم التي سيحاكم عليها فيما يامي اليوم
طبعا يوم السبت وخلال تجمع جماهير قالت
ترامب ان الشعب الامريكي غاضب وان المعركه
النهائيه جاريه لانفاذ البلاد على حد قوله
كما ردد بعض العبارات التي استخدمها قبل
الهجوم على الكابيتال في يناير 2021 طبعا
تعليقات ترامب واذا ما اضفنا اليها تجربه
الكابيتال اطلقت اشارات التحذير فيما يامي
التي اعلن قائد شرطتها مانوال موريس ان
السلطات المحليه وضعت بالحسبان احتماليه
ان تاخذ الامور منعطفا نحو الاسوا طبعا
صحيفه
استطلعت اراء محللين منهم جمهوريون اشار
البعض لان ترامب وبعيدا عن الجانب
القانوني سيعمل على كسب الجمهور من خلال
تصوير نفسه على انه مضطهد وانه خاطر
باثاره التوتر السياسي او حتى العنف بينما
قال احد الناشطين الجمهوريين المقربين من
ترامب ان الاخير سيحاول كل ما في وسعه
لابطاء المحاكمه مما يمنحه فرصه اكبر
لايصال رسائله السياسيه قبل اصدار اي حكم
مساعدونا سابقون للترامب اكدوا ان مواقفه
مبرره وانها ستس اعده سياسيا خاصه مع
تصدره لاستطلاعات الراي في الحزب الجمهوري
الا انهم ابدوا تخوفهم من ان تلقي لائحه
الاتهام الفيدراليه تلقي بظلالها عليه في
الانتخابات العامه بينما قال اكاديميون
لفايناشل تايمز ان وجود رئيس سابق في
مواجهه ضد القضاء هو امر خطير قد تكون له
عواقب بعيده المدى ربما تجعل الثقه في
المسار القانوني هشه للغايه
طبعا نعود الى ضيوفنا من واشنطن السيد
بشار جرار الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن
واشنطن الدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في
الشؤون
السياسيه يعني
دكتور عقيل يعني وفق كل المعطيات هل
سيستطيع ترامب او سيكون قادرا حتى النهايه
على رص صفوف الجمهوريين وقطع الطريق امام
منافسيه تحديدا ديسانتس لانه بكل خطاباته
يظهر نفسه بانه هو المستهدف الوحيد بالحزب
الجمهوري ليكسب بالنهايه بطبيعه الحال
اصوات الجمهوريين
تنتهي الان اعذرني يا استاذ عقيل تنتهي في
هذه اللحظات اذا جلسه الاستماع تماما وفقا
لسي ان ان تفضل دكتور
هو هو متصدر يتصدر كل المتنافسين
الجمهوريين
واذا مضت الاشياء على النحو الحالي اعتقد
هو الذي سيفوز
يعني ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري هذا طبعا يخرج
المرشحين الاخرين الذين يضطرون للسكوت رغم
انه يعني بدات تظهر بدايات الاعتراض على
هيمنه ترامب وعلى ما يمكن القول هو اختطاف
الحزب الجمهوري يعني بعض مثلا في ولايه
تنسى الجمهوري وهو يعني نائب جمهوري متشدد
ربما في المعسكر الذي في العاده ينتمي
اليه ترامب لا بدا يظهر انه هذا خطا ولا
يمكن دعم الرئيس ترامب في قضيه كهذه علينا
ان ننتظر ونرى اذا اذا مضت اراده على
الاقل يبدو لحد الان الاراده الفيدراليه
اراده المحكمه الفيدراليه الاتحاديه كما
عبر عنها
ربما هو يريد هذا بمحاكمه سريعه بمعنى لا
انتظار يستمر عاما بحيث
ابات قبل ان يتم البدء في هذه القضيه ان
تم البث في هذه القضيه قبل اجراء
الانتخابات اعتقد ترامب سيكون في وضع حرج
وحرج جدا ستظهر المزيد من الحقائق يعني
بخصوص ما قام به وهذه تقوض مكانته في داخل
الحزب الجمهوري المعروف بانه حزب متشدد في
القضايا المتعلقه بالامن على الاسرار يعني
اعتقد المشهد مفتوح على احتمالات متعدده
ليست في صالح ترامب يعاكس قضيه نيويورك
دكتور عقيل تاثير في الانتخابات لضيفنا
استاذ بشار جرار البعض يقول بانه ووفقا
ايضا لبعض استطلاعات الراي بانه كل ما
يحصل معه مع ترامب يخدمه الان ويعزز موقعه
وبالتالي كيف لنا ان نتخيل ان المحاكمه
سياسيه
هل يريد الحزب الديمقراطي واداره بايدن ان
تعزز من موقع ترامب في الانتخابات كيف ترد
على هذه النقطه
تصدق نعم عزيزي
وهو
وانا لا استبعد شخصيا ذلك بانه لا يمكن ان
ينجح بايدن الا اذا قال ان البديل هو
ترامب حتى في داخل الاسر يعني باوساط
العرب الامريكيين هناك انقسام حول هذه
المساله لا شك ان الرئيس ترامب كشخص مثير
للجدل ولا الانقسام لا شك بانه حاد الطباع
انا دائما استخدم هذا المصطلح بانه
بمعنى حتى تكون حاسما احيانا لابد ان تتخذ
موقفا يقسم الناس الى معسكرين واضحين هذه
ميزه ومشكله ترامب واعتقد ان نعم هذا
محاوله يعني عندما ترى الاعلام كله
والقضاء يتجه باتجاه واحد فقط هو محاوله
عرقله ترشيح
لانه قادم من خارج الوسط وهذا ما يفسر هذه
المق التي كما يقال كلمه حق يراد بها باطل
يعني هذه متداوله جدا في الاعلام العالمي
وليس فقط الامريكي بان ترامب والترامبيين
بانه سرق الحزب الجمهوري غير
صحيح لانه ما زال حتى الان ايقونه لدى
الجمهوريين ولدي المحافظين ترامب ليس
بالمحافظ كما هو مثلا
كما اراد لينسي جرام السيناتور عندما طرح
قضيه الاجهاض في توقيت قاتل في الانتخابات
التمهيديه فادى الى خساره الرد ويف التي
توقعناها كجمهوريه محافظين لانه مجرد
اثاره قضيه الاجهاض ادى الى خساره ولايات
وخساره كثير من الانتخابات ومنها اريزونا
التي كانت شبه مؤكده ستذهب الى حاكمه من
الجمهوريين المحافظين المسيحيين المهتذرين
هذا عزيزتي ويا عزيزي بان ما يجري هو
محاوله صناعه الوعي وتوجيه وباتجاه بان
ترامب الان يعملون ضده ولكن سينقلب هذا
الامر نعم هناك اكثر من جهه تعمل ضد ترامب
الدوله العميقه المؤسسه مؤسسه حتى الحزب
الجمهوري المؤسسه التي ستضرر من قرار هو
قال تعهد من الان قال انه سيقم حرب
اوكرانيا قال انه لن يرضى باي حرب خارجيه
امريكيه لابس الشرق الاوسط ولا غير الشرق
الاوسط هناك من يتقرر يا عزيزي هل هي
اموال الطاقه كثيره
ومنها
بان الكوفيد كان مصنع فيروس مصنع في بوها
نعم
نعم شكرا جزيلا لك السيد بشار جرار الكاتب
والمحلل للسياسي حدثنا من واشنطن وايضا
للدكتور عقيل عباس الخبير في الشؤون
السياسيه الامريكيه شكرا لكما
كعادتي كل قضيه متعلقه بالترامب تنقسم
الولايات المتحده الى معسكرين في الاول
هناك مؤيدون للرجل باستماته وفي الثاني
كرهونا لوجوده السياسي وفي الحالتين يبدو
التاييد او الكره مرتبطين الى حد كبير
بسباق الرئاسه في العمل القادم
[موسيقى]
رحلات ترامب تعددت قبل الوصول الى محطه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه العامه المقبل غير ان
رحلته الابرز التي تشوبها الكثير من
المخاطر تلك التي يخوضها في مواجهه القضاء
الرئيس الاكثر اثاره للجدل في تاريخ
الولايات المتحده بين مدافعين عنه
ومنتقدين له ابرز ردود الافعال اتخذت
اتجاهين متعاكسين حد الاصطدام والمواجهه
حلفاء ترامب يستميتون في الدفاع عنه
ويستنكرون ما سموها ملاحقات سياسيه
محاميته اكدت ان الترامب كل الحق في
الاحتفاظ بوثائق بعد ان رفعت عنها السريه
النائب الجمهوري جيم جوردان كرر ان
المحاكمه من تدبير معسكر الرئيس
الديمقراطي جو بايدن رغم ان لائحه الاتهام
تبنتها هيئه محلفين كبرى من المواطنين في
فلوريدا رئيس بلديه ميامي الجمهور فرانسيس
سواريز عبر عن امله في ان تمر الامور
بسلام
داعيا الناس الى ان يكونوا مسالمين في
اظها
ر هذه ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام صور المغادره
مغادره الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
للمحكمه في ميامي بفلوريدا حيث مثل امام
جلسه استماع ما استمع لسات الطبيعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حسين معنا
حسين تسمعني
[تصفيق]
منقل لنا الصوره لو سمحت نعم انا اسمع
يعني طبيعي
يغادر الان
ارى ارى ان بعض الناس يركضون بالاتجاه
الاخر يبدو انه غادر المحكمه للتو طبعا
الامور خفضت على هذه الجهه حتى بدانا نسمع
بعض هناك اصوات من الجهه المقابله
يحيي الجمهور ساطلب من المزامير المصور ان
ان نذهب الى هناك
على امل حسين احسان نشاهد الان على الشاشه
صوره موكب الرئيس السابق يمكنك التعليق عن
الاجواء وعن المناصرين حيث تتواجد
نشاهده الان اذا يلوح
المناصرون راويه
نعم يغادر الان المناصرون يتجهون الى
يغادروا
الجهه الخلفيه للمحكمه غدا من الجهه
الاخرى لم يكن متوقعا ذلك كنا نتوقع ان لا
يلوح للمناصرين
كي لا يعني بطلب كي لا يستغل ذلك اعلاميا
ولكنه يبدو انه فعلها
كما قلت الامور خفته الان مقارنه بما كانت
عليه في ساعات قليله الماضيه
الحماس خف قليلا كان هناك حضور قوي من قبل
المناصري
سلامتك سلامتك
الرئيس السابق يغادر المحكمه الفيدراليه
في ميامي فلوريدا بعد جلسه الاستماع التي
انهيت قبل قليل وهناك اعتقالات يبدو في
صفوف بعض من كان يتظاهر في محيط هذه
المحكمه نرى بوضوح رجال الامن وهم يحاولون
تقييد احد المتجاوزين نستمع الى صوت طبيعي
[موسيقى]
نستمع ايضا الى هتافات طاهر
لمناصريه ترامب او كما يقال لهم
الترامبيين طبعا
ترامب غادر مقر المحكمه محكمه في فلوريدا
وبعد السماح له طبعا
بمغادرتها من دون شروط هذه هذا الظهور
الثاني طبعا
للترامب في قاعه المحكمه كمتهم جنائي بعد
محكمه امام محكمه نيويورك في ابريل الماضي
بتهمه التزوير وثائق على صله بدفع لاحدى
الممثلات مقابل طبعا التستر على علاقتها
به وهو الامر الذي رفضه
ترامب اذا حسين الان بين يعني هذه في خضام
هذه الفوضى التي تعم حسين ما الذي يحصل
عندك
بين المتظاهرين هناك تدافع
لاعب لماذا يتم اعتقال هذا الرجل
[ضحك]
وانا بقوه
الشرطه طاهر نعم هناك
تدافعات التي تطلق او لماذا تم اعتقاله ان
علم
ورجل مسن كمان
من المتظاهرين
لا كان من المتطهرين المؤترام
يبدو انه تبع الموكب
غادر بالفعل
الان عندما وصلنا كان قد غادر
كما قلنا طاهر في سبقات في نشرات السابقه
كان هناك حضور مكثف والشرطه
كانت مستعده للتعامل
في الحقيقه لم نشاهد احداث عرس في طيله
هذا النهار كانت الامور مضبوطه كانت
الاجواء احتفاليه رغم التحضيرات الامنيه
المكثفه تحسبا لما يمكن ان يحصل اعذرني
على المقاطعه ولكن انتهى وقت هذه الساعه
ويجب ان نتوجه بعد قليل الى زميله ميسون
نؤيد في اخبار الساعه لتتابع في هذه
التغطيه نرى في الصوره اذا موكب الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب بعد مغادرته المحكمه
الفيدراليه في ميامي اضافه الى جزء اخر من
الصوره نشاهد فيه تظاهرات المستمره التي
كانت في محيط المحكمه من انصار ترامب اذا
غادرت ترامب من دون فرد اي قيود عليه في
المحكمه الاولى في قضيه الوثائق السريه
طبعا الزميله ميسون ويهت تتابع معكم هذه
التغطيه في اخبار الساعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات